[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
t'es pas mal non c'est d'ailleurs là si
on dirait laurent 2 non non non non non
non non non non mais ça alors on va
faire ce que je laisse pousser la barbe
l'album je suis en train de lui faire un
look mais deus ex 3 me ouais bah on va
vivre ça sent bon la whey ces jours ci
mais ça sent bon mais vous parlez de
l'émission pour aller là bas merci paris
cédric c'est mieux l'annoncé mieux déjà
pas de cheveux si votre fils cédric goût
bah c'est surtout pour moi c'est pas le
sien mais moi mais je suis surtout
jamais les mêmes choses que quand tu as
un beau crâne oui et evo julia oui vous
benhaim ah oui bah jeudi d'un tatami
jason orientale hors des mecs choses non
à plusieurs mains
[Applaudissements]
c'était dans l'émission greg lemond
l'acadie 6 me dérange pas si elle est
assumée et comme cédric la suède a subi
là et bal à ce niveau là t'es foutu les
mecs aussi il ya des codes maison une
messe à coups de bâton un sommet commun
cette part comment ça s'est fait comme
ça dit elle repart et où ils sont avalés
avec une chemin mon frère ils te font
tout cas moi j'ai voilà est exact qu'il
évolue partout sauf du crâne il est
partout sauf du crâne lever les fonds je
vais vous dire
jean-michel dès qu'il a une info c'est
qu'elle est bonne c'est exact merci jean
moulin combien cela dit vous avez des
cheveux magnifiques et je sais qu'ils
sont naturels bravo change de place vous
mettre l'adresse nations et les acheter
emballé alors ce soir dans les lauriers
images exclusives de cyril hanouna en
terre inconnue chez jean marie le pen
il a notamment donné son avis sur
certains d'entre vous allez voir un
ancien président de la république il
fait son retour dans les médias
et pour finir on fêtera les neuf ans
touche pas à mon poste avec une surprise
vous allez voir si c'est une petite
surprise
alors si elle menait depuis jeudi vous
avez donc ajouté une ligne à votre cv
peut-être interviewer politique de
terrain oui puisque vous avez installé
chez jean marie le pen pour lui poser
des questions et immédiatement je vous
remets le laurier de l'animateur qui va
dès demain piquer la place de
jean-pierre elkabbach
dès votre première question c'est
magnifique
ce que vous êtes raciste ça sympa
commentaire alors comme elle capable
cette hyper cool avec votre invité
vraiment pour moi vous étiez antisémite
vous étiez racisées qui est homophobe
voilà pendant l'interview avait dû
beaucoup répéter vos questions et là ils
entendaient pas trop gens que vous
connaissez
eric naulleau karim zéribi et moi mais
ce que vous ne connaissiez ou pas du
tout est-ce que je me connais et c'est
quoi être français jean-paul comment
quelles sont vos rêves vos rapports avec
votre fille marine le pen avec me paie
un loyer jean marie le pen
il commence vous allez votez pour qui
aux élections européennes commencent
dans sa configuration actuelle comment
les dix cas depuis près de 40 ans
audika n'est ce pas parce que la base
séquentielle vous faites style que vous
connaissez le politicien n'ont pas
encore marie le pen alors qu'on sait
très bien qu'ils avaient un regret
candidat président politique de syrie le
regarder
bien que mais mon frère s'est pas
démentie
[Applaudissements]
il m'a sorti un blaze mon frère je sais
comment je sais pas quoi 1812 des 925
millions attendus vous faites très bien
bravo en tout cas alors syrie je vous
connais par coeur je vous soupçonne
d'avoir voulu faire un entretien et jean
marie le pen uniquement pour lui faire
votre interio favorite dar kaoua sera
trop bas non pas que pour ça qu'on
regarde mais alors vous avez tout tenté
pour qu'il dise l'un de ces mots
vraiment vous êtes tout en bas ouais ça
allait faire dire un mot arabe à jean
marie le pen c'est plus dur que de
grimper le voulait absolument pour moi
c'était une grande victoire
voilà pour tous les jours qui nous
regardent mais c'est vrai que ça a été
dur un haut niveau
passez pas quoi y avait un truc qui j'ai
pas y avait un truc qui bloquait là on
va le voir oui vraiment tout tenté mais
jamais remarqué ouais que et mine de
rien et il a du mal à me regarder moi
beaucoup de mal oui là laissez vous pas
c'est vrai il ya beaucoup les autres
mais wade idy nord il va m'attaquer sur
la tête de r&d coma
sinon il va m'attaquez lui je veux pas
parler à cette personne j'ai pas osé de
faire ça mais victime ce que tu peux je
peux je peux tout faire ça qui est bien
je remercie riehl hanouna le laurier du
gars qui n'arrêtera pas son interview
tant que le pen n'aura pas prononcé le
mot d'arca huras regarde race rats ou
data ratera donc la race raoudha retard
hidetaka cercle d'art qu'aura sera donc
john d'arcade donkey lemmy d'arcade il
ratera c'est un bon scénario pour des
filiales nicolas sarkozy ce serait quoi
non mais si on repassera au dark à dar
kaoua sera barca d'arc a donc j'en
arrive presque vous pouvez bien ils sont
d'arca il a dit plutôt ça donne un parc
aquatique
ça veut dire oui mais faut dire
d'arcachon je voulais pas le barca bon
resto bar 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cyril nous a pas oubliés chers amis
chroniqueur voilà il a eu des demandes
demandé à jean marie le pen ce qu'ils
pensaient de certains d'entre vous voilà
sa réponse et qui le pen sympathique
marca on est prêt ouais euh vous l'aimez
pas voulu non non vous ne vendez pas que
je trouve sympathique eux
beurk extrêmement drôle c'est gentil
merci hommage soit pas dans l'émission
est-ce que vous souvenez tous d'un
certain françois hollande bien sûr c'est
un homme porté disparu comme le parti
socialiste hier on dira sonraï des
gosses beau et jeune fille ouais les
mecs
non mais c'est géraldine oui non il est
pas mal il a quelque chose mais disons
que ce n'est pas ce qui caractérise
collet était là il a un truc en tout cas
il est très sympathique et très drôle
c'est vrai que je les ai vus là dans la
foi était sympathique mais bon sans dire
voilà ça très drôle
un truc il va d'abord il a beaucoup de
sens par son humour dr et ouais valérie
dernier se retire avec françois hollande
alors l'intelligence est assez sexy
c'est vrai mais bon ou alors je me suis
pas du tout alors pour le coup là tu
vois
kelis il était plus jeune françois
hollande avec la même tête non julia
julia l'intelligence important avec
c'est essentiel mais c'est vrai non bah
ouais après bon c'est physique suisse et
c'est encore mieux mais et si aucun des
deux bons mois par exemple la
gentillesse et la voilà moi c'est pas la
pression c'est vrai que moi je m'en sors
donc s agit donc il faut la gentillesse
non vraiment les gêner gaïa les superbes
volées lancement attention il rigole pas
ah il a enlevé ses lunettes
qu'est ce qu'il ya mais c'est moi j'ai
trouvé ça super parce que c'est toi qui
fait l'histoire
on a l'habitude de penser que les lois
de l'histoire et que toi que tu y ailles
toi toi tu fais l'histoire un peu à ta
façon je crois plus à l'histoire faite
par les hommes qu'à l'histoire ali et
les hommes imaginent dire que l'histoire
que c'est plus facile de dire que c'est
l'effort qui fait je record mais moi tu
fais l'histoire là
bonsoir bonsoir je parlais de françois
hollande donc l'ancien président de
république est passionné de croissants
au beurre et de scooters alors il est
payé hier chez laurent delahousse et
l'assemblée de mauvais poil alors je
remets à françois hollande le laurier du
gars qui a décidé de dire non à tout ce
que demande laurent delahousse juste
parce qu'ils le trouvent trop beau gosse
première question est ce que vous étiez
invité à vous rendre sur le plateau des
glières
non je n'étais pas invitée je reçois
aussi quoi un homme qui n'a pas arrêté
la politique donc là pourquoi pour
quelle raison parce que ça fait un peu
retraités sincèrement non c'est une
impossibilité donc est ce que vous êtes
rentré dans un affrontement clair avec
finalement emmanuel macron ne rejoint
est ce que vous allez soutenir une liste
où vous tirait tout simplement non vous
n'avez pas avant dimanche
non évidemment françois hollande s'est
mis à chanter on sait pas pourquoi
non non non
non non non c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
il est caustique j'essaye j'essaye alors
je nie dans touche pas à mon poste nous
avons reçu les harlem globetrotters
ce sont des génies du basket capable
ce sont des génies du basket capable de
marquer un panier les yeux bandés et
sans les mains enfin ça c'est d'habitude
parce que l'époque dans l'émission ça a
été compliqué ah oui alors je leur
remets les l'orée des invités qui
avaient oublié que ces huit c'était la
chaîne officielle de la scoumoune
il était samedi dans l'expresso sur bing
sport l'émission qui réveille les
téléspectateurs et on avait l'impression
de voir jouer des basketteurs de nba
c'était impressionnant regardez-moi ça
[Musique]
d'ailleurs tous qui rentre
et c'est vous parce que la veille dans
des pmp hd ready des mecs qui jouait
pour la première fois de leur vie au
basket
[Musique]
alors la médiation total c'est quand
même que doc gynéco a été meilleur que
ces gamins en matière et non quatre
jardins 3 et c'est tout
harlem globe trotteuse y performent
basket a fait du basket frémont même pas
une fois que tu touché un ballon
si j'avais pas touché un ballon depuis
de nombreuses années mais c'est ouf mais
tu étais beau basket a toujours été bon
basket dans tous les jeux de ballons
j'ai en fait j'ai il m'a filé une balle
un moment il m'a dit le crib all away et
la chance du débutant
alors franchement d'allocations tout a
tellement magnifique franchement et ben
tu sais quoi où vas tu inscrire à la hes
basket l'école
alors aujourd'hui le monde entier ne
parle que d'une chose les neuf ans ne
touche pas à mon pote c'est à la preuve
avec cette revue de presse mondiale
regardez-moi ça tout le monde ne parle
que du jimmy fallon tunisie à regarder
ça va partir et évoluent non non ça veut
pas repentez d'accord il ya tout ce
mélange en même temps c'est moi en régie
comment les naïades ya des choses qui se
bousculent la mondiale regardez-moi ça
ouais tunisienne jimmy fallon the sun
carte au foehn d'arc à faire ça c'est
incroyable et vous fêterez ça jeudi dans
une soirée exceptionnelle sur scène
c'est vrai dès 19h dès 19h alors pour se
mettre dans l'ambiance d'essayer de
remettre chaque soir un baba du poste
qui récompense les meilleurs moments des
neuf dernières années et c'est vous qui
désignerez le gagnant ce soir celui du
meilleur fous rires les nommés sont à ça
c'est bien khadr
connu sous le nom de matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
géraldine mayer qu'il ya de petits
problèmes de mémoire des éditeurs de
paris flammarion les éditions de minuit
et quand je leur dis que s'est
poursuivie la nina au départ les mandats
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
trois temps jean michel maire qui fait à
la fois de la corde à sauter et du
naturisme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
michel merle et kate barca magnifique
merci beaucoup merci bonsoir
[Applaudissements]